all right so uh we turn now to a story
about award-winning Chef Emeril Lagasse
who became a national figure as a host
of several popular cooking shows but in
New Orleans he's known for his Flagship
restaurant emeralds now it's been an
institution in that City for more than
30 years now his restaurant is
undergoing some big big changes thanks
to the new Young chef at the helm look I
see son EJ
CBS Saturday morning co-host Michelle
Miller met up with Father and Son to see
how things are going in the kitchen as
EJ charts his own path the chicken in
the kitchen of this legendary New
Orleans restaurant
there's a new Chef in charge it was a
constant communication we were all going
last night his name is EJ Lagasse and
he's redefining what it means to eat
here let's have a great service
he might seem a little young for his job
you're 19. I thought you turned 20. no
so 20 in in March how did you begin this
process every young kid has a thing that
I'm going to play a sport I'll be in the
Olympics or something like that that
just wasn't what it was for me but it's
not for a lack of experience he
graduated culinary school last May a and
his Apprentice with the steamed chefs in
celebrated kitchens all over the world
at age 10 he told his parents he wanted
to become a chef we were out at dinner
and I sat them down and I just said I
was like oh yeah by the way guys uh like
I'm gonna this is what I'm gonna do and
the first words he was like you you sure
about that and I was like yeah yeah yeah
the skeptic he was referring to his dad
Chef Emeril Lagasse the namesake of this
very restaurant which he opened more
than 30 years ago before his culinary
Empire took off little lesson spam bam
bam bam oh a little vanilla ice cream
Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam it's almost
like you groomed him for this
no he he did it on his own I never I
never ever had a conversation with him
to say this is what you need to do not
one time EJ was exposed to the world
stage as a tyke one tablespoon and his
dad was his inspiration
[Laughter]
I was set up for that do you want to do
TV I'm not opposed to it you know what I
mean but uh if it's a camera and a stove
and teaching people how to cook let's do
it that's my that's my view your dad's
kind of known for his catchphrases
I figured this was coming do you have
one no no I don't I don't I mean maybe
one will come at some point but in the
kitchen too busy and a bit sweaty to
come up with a catchphrase busy helping
revamp the dining experience here at
emeralds were just 60 guests per night
are treated to a newly designed tasting
menu why is it necessary to take this
approach is it just the evolutionary
process that happens with with an
establishment that can last as long as
this if you stay stagnant and you're
content with the way that things are
going how can you continue to have Cooks
walk in the back door with that hunger
to learn that hunger to grow in
themselves he's also introducing updated
methods to see the process now of these
guys testing dishes like he's testing
dishes right now with the team for the
spring menu already we and that's been
going on for 30 days at least we're in
the summer menu now actually we're
testing this summer we finished we
finished the spring
see that
I like taking his old dishes that are
old of course and uh and change them up
and putting his own spin on his dad's
time-tested dishes
back in the kitchen I tasted one of EJ's
additions to the menu scallops on a bed
of lentils with crispy chicken skin and
brown butter foam it's pretty delicious
it is so layered are you ever policing
your dad no I wouldn't say so yeah no I
think that there's there's I think that
there's policing when it comes to if I
take a classic dish and I do something
that's just a too far out there he'll be
in and he'll be like
that's the only policing that takes
place
for Lagasse his son's changes are
indicative of a larger evolution of the
emerald brand you're sold on
his whole approach to food
yes
you hesitated so I had to think about
that for a second because you know what
in life
sometimes passing the torch is not as
easy as it sounds
but when you're confident of passing the
torch then it becomes much easier and
you have every Faith yeah we're creating
something out of absolute love and so
when we come in and we get to do that
with passion and love and respect for
the past but also you know an eye on the
on the future of what's happening with
dining worldwide I mean it's the it's
the greatest joy ever for CBS mornings
Michelle Miller in New Orleans
Beautiful father-son Moments there it's
difficult to pass the torch she got
Emerald sauce son thinking son was
thinking yeah almost like it hit him
right there yeah I I was looking at the
very same thing yeah that was well done
well done very nice